you have two potential solutions to a
problem solution a
and solution b in local tests solution a
performs extremely well
outperforming solution b but as you
deploy it out at massive scales you find
things grinding to a halt
out of desperation you deploy solution b
which works smoothly
what's going on here and more
importantly how could you have seen this
coming
let's start with some examples if you
have an array of unsorted items
finding the index of an element means
that you have to iterate through the
entire list
checking every single one contrast that
to if the array was sorted
so if the array was sorted that means
that you can use something like binary
search
you pick the middle point compare if the
value is above or below you can discard
half the list and then do the same on
the remaining portion
intuitively without any sort of
mathematical framework
you can kind of see that the first has
to visit every single item
in the array in the absolute worst case
where the item isn't in the array
well with the second since you discard
half the array after the first iteration
and each subsequent loop progressively
discards half of the remaining you only
need to do a few steps
more formally the first loop is big o of
n
or order n while the second is order log
n
let's understand what those mean in
mathematics big o
notation is a tool for helping us
understand the growth of a function
as x increases formally it's defined
like this
that is if there exists a positive real
number m
and a real number x sub zero such that
the absolute value of f at x
is less than or equal to m times g at x
for all x greater than or equal to x sub
0 blah blah blah blah blah
personally a lot of this page just reads
like a steaming pile of
math notation so let's look at some
pictures instead
pictures are always better here's a
graph of f
x so it'll just kind of do some crap
here and then head up
and then let's add a second function
here call it g at x
so what that complicated definition is
saying is that
if there's some point on this graph
where g at x
times any constant is higher than f at x
and it stays higher after that then f at
x
is order g at x so
we backtrack and here's f of x again but
this time let's say that g
at x is actually the function x squared
so you get this curve since f of x is
less than x squared around this point
and after that it stays under there
forever so f of x is order x squared
computing big o so you have an equation
like you've got 2x or 4x squared plus 7x
plus three
or x to the power five plus a hundred
thousand it doesn't matter
let's just work through a few of these
so what you wanna do is select the
dominant term
that means you focus on the fastest
growing term drop the constant and
ignore pretty much everything else so f
at x equals 2x
is order x since x was the dominant term
f of x equals 4x squared plus 7x plus 3
is order x squared and f at x equals
x squared plus a hundred thousand it's
order x to the power five
here are some of the most common ones
with examples of algorithms or code
so order one that's constant time so
like an array or a hash table
lookup what are login that's log time
or logarithmic time and an easy example
is binary search
order n that's linear time so that would
be something like finding in an unsorted
array and often
radix sort like sorting instant floats
is grouped in with this
there's order n log n this has a bunch
of different names
we'll go with quasi linear anyway this
is comparison sorts like merge sort and
there's
order n squared quadratic bubble sort
comes to mind
use a bigger list if you want to go
through them all can't say
personally run into a lot of these but
they're interesting
so take a look how this relates to
performance
in computer science when we're talking
about the big o of an algorithm
we're more talking about something like
either the time it takes to run
or the memory it uses given ever larger
inputs
what we're in essence doing is looking
at the time or the number of steps an
algorithm takes
as the size of the import gets bigger
going back to the first example
the unsorted array you can see that as
the array gets bigger
the time in the worst case to search the
array also gets bigger
linearly in fact if the array is 10
elements long
we might take 10 iterations of a loop to
search the whole thing
in the worst case whatever the array is
a million elements long
and the worst case will loop 1 million
times so the growth
was exactly proportional to the size of
the array
contrast that to binary search if we
start with a small array of elements
it takes just a few steps to converge to
an answer in the worst case
and if we were to expand that to a
million elements
because of the logarithmic nature of the
algorithm it doesn't take that many more
steps to sort through
even though it's so much bigger and of
course there's gotchas
in the strictest terms big o describes
the upper bound of an algorithm
it specifically says that your function
f at x won't grow faster than
m times g at x for some m but that also
means that something that's
order n for example is also order n
squared
because if it doesn't grow faster than
order n it definitely doesn't grow
faster than n
squared and so on so technically
if you're one of those people you can
just answer order n factorial or
something like that anytime someone asks
for the big o running time of an
algorithm
and you'll probably be right you won't
like pass an interview or even be
marginally useful as a co-worker but
being technically correct is more
important anyway
here's another thing to note in software
engineering we tend to use big
o a bit differently that is to describe
roughly how fast we expect something to
run
like with quicksort we often refer to it
as order n log n
but that's kind of the average case and
it's often stated separately to have a
worst case of order n squared
so we kind of play a bit fast and loose
with the definitions and terminology of
big o
when something more like big theta might
make more sense so just keep that in
mind
so how do i use this it kind of gives
you a sense of how something will scale
given larger and larger inputs so if
you're looking at two algorithms like
the unsorted search
and the sorted binary search you can
kind of intuit that the
unsorted search grows linearly and the
other grows logarithmically
and you can conclude that the binary
search version will
outperform the first one but there's
some subtlety here
this gets me to my story and what was in
the title
so a long long time ago i was
interviewing at google
past the phone screen and i was at the
onsite making my way through the rounds
with engineers
one of the interviewers was quizzing me
on subjects near the end of our
interview
at some point we started talking about
big o analysis and i
rambled a bunch on the subject gave what
i thought was a decent answer
and then stupidly decided to be smart
and throw in some extra detail
since big o is often describing the
dominant term
and the others are dropped when you're
doing micro optimizations
what's interesting is that those can
actually be super important
for example it's entirely possible for
say an order n
algorithm to outperform in order log n1
on small inputs because of those
constants that aren't reflected in big o
if you remember those graphs we looked
at big o defines the limiting behavior
as the input gets huge but at smaller
values it doesn't necessarily say
anything
as you can guess this was a bad idea he
interrupted me quickly shutting down the
idea
said i was just wrong on this i remember
being pretty nervous and thinking
okay this guy's a google engineer i
looked up to these people as super smart
and
figured i just explained totally wrong
so i gave the benefit of the doubt
and replied that at huge scale like
google deals with
algorithmic complexity will trump
everything but what i'm talking about is
game optimization
and small inputs it's entirely possible
for those smaller terms to matter a lot
he cut me off again and said that's not
how it works order n
is slower than log n so i tried to
clarify again
and said that's definitely true for
larger values but at smaller values it
might not be true
it's possible the effects of things like
caching branch prediction
and he cut me off again this time he
kind of snapped and said that
it sounds like i don't understand big o
at all this felt a little off the rails
by now
and unfortunately that's how the
interview ended
we were out of time when the next
interviewer was knocking on the door so
i didn't feel great about that interview
ended up still getting an offer and i
was at google for many years
and did many interviews myself so it
worked out fine
definitely a low light of the process
though the subtlety here is that with
let's say order n versus log n as an
example
order log n will definitely be faster
eventually
as n approaches infinity look at the
definition again
f of x is order g at x if there exists a
positive constant
m and a real number x sub zero
such that f of x is less than or equal
to m times g
at x for x greater than or equal to x
sub zero and that's the important part
for some x sub 0 not every single value
so if the original equations were
something more like 0.001
n versus a thousand log n let's just be
contrived here
that's order n versus order log n but if
you graph those you'll notice yes of
course
eventually log n will be better but this
whole
area here this is where the
asymptotically worse algorithm
outperformed the supposedly faster one
in a game
we're not usually concerned with
infinity in fact we may know for
absolute certain that there's at most a
thousand entities
or fifty thousand particles or whatever
so in those cases where we know the
domain well
big o doesn't necessarily tell us the
whole story
hope you found this useful subscribe and
comment and of course
if i got anything wrong let me know
politely
see you next time cheers